another thing that dr bride is not
allowed to do at the foundation no
leading a mobile task force against the
uiu under any circumstances the unusual
incidence unit of the fbi is a generally
well-meaning but often irritating
presence in the world of anomalous
research it's the annoying little
brother who insists on following you and
your friends around when you're trying
to play big boy games for crying out
loud but that doesn't mean that it's
acceptable to lead a mobile task force
against them with bright's newly formed
task force he approached a uiu building
and proceeded to order a series of ding
dong ditches where the task force
members would ring the doorbell and then
run away laughing before anyone could
catch them they also covered the
exterior of the building in eggs toilet
paper and a substance later revealed to
be a lightly radioactive form of silly
string though no real damage was done
this behavior was described by the o5
council as just kind of mean dr bright
has been prohibited from leading any
more task forces in the future